our subject for this afternoon the great
controversy what did i say the great controversy
god is good and all the time who is with us now
who was not here this morning miss your hands
thank you very much for coming we're
delighted you've chosen to join us
you have had or we have had a long day am i right
and i will keep this in mind as i deliver the
remarks i believe god has placed rather heavily on
my heart before i do that uh who's with us who is
not a seventh-day adventist makes your hand any
nonsense god bless you nice to see you thank you
so much for coming were you here this morning
well good you were one of us then all right
anyone else you're not a seventh-day adventist
just raise your hand where are you anyone else
where is that a hand you reason no i thought this
brother was pointing out somebody else all right
so we just have one distinguished non-seventh-day
advocate god but what's your name oh yes yes yes
all right i met you last night okay and there's
no one else okay that's not good we should invite
our friends who were not seventh-day adventists
are you with me no you're not are you with me
we must invite our friends so they can benefit
from what god has given to us do i need this
i don't okay will i ruin it if i do that all right
uh it's um a quarter to eight is that quarters
of eight i have a quarter to 11 michigan time i
should be done by i'll try to be finished by 8 15.
just give you a a sabbath end sermonette
no you have had a long day and so have i
but i'll see what the holy ghost says before
i go any further do three easy favors for me
favor number one if you have a cell
phone i would like you to turn it off
please don't rebel it's a very dangerous thing
to rebel against a preacher who's standing doing
god's work i mean if he's on the golf course
that's something else when he's in the desk
doing god's work you better be careful how you
respond to his requests all cell phones turned off
are they all off don't lie in the
presence of god are they all off
who is having a hard time turning it off can i see
your hair all right my brother
keep working on it turn it off
oh i'll ask god to ruin it turn it off turn it off
no it's amazing how rebellious people are in the
church just because i ask please turn them off
the cardinal mind says he can't tell me what to
do which is true so i'm just asking very nicely
please what's it in spanish for favor please turn
them off favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and all i want you to say is lord put your
words in that man's mouth and favor number three
i want you to think of what you're
hearing don't just sit and listen
think of what you're hearing let's pray holy
father in heaven my request is very simple
i ask you to god to possess my mind put your
words in my mouth and grant me a humble spirit
i seek only your glory and
the blessing of your people
so forgive my sins cleanse my heart day god
make me a fit vessel for this spiritual task
and father let the spirit in me be the spirit
in your people who listen that the words leaving
the throne of grace entering my mind exiting my
lips may enter their hearts unbroken unchanged
that at the end of the service their god we may
all be drawn close to your bosom glorifying you
and reveling in the truth i offer this
prayer from my heart in jesus name amen
let me make an observation it is not just common
uh unique to you it's common wherever i go
when you pray pray to god father through
the holy spirit in the name of jesus
you know ellen white frequently
refers to salvation as a science
are you with me have you ever heard
the expression the science of salvation
the science of prayer there
is a way to pray you pray
to god the father you pray through the holy spirit
who knows really what it is you and i want to say
even when we groan he interprets that into the
language of heaven and you pray in the name
of jesus is that simple enough i have seen
this thing turned upside down wherever i go
because we take a casual approach to doing
things a certain way there is a way to pray
i'll tell you something else we are to exercise
repentance towards god and faith in the lord jesus
you're lost and you look it let me
say it again we are to exercise faith
repentance towards god the father and faith in the
lord jesus and faith in the lord jesus is faith
in all that he did and accomplished through
his all-powerful all-sufficient atonement
you don't pray to the holy ghost
and you don't pray in the name of the father
you exercise faith in jesus and you
offer repentance towards the father
it's a very arranged and organized system are you
with me are you finding these details troublesome
you sure at least now you know and it's up to
you what you'll do you know i was at a church
the last church i had the great pleasure of
pastoring and i was explaining to my members
i want you to be sophisticated not stuck up
there are two different things when you pick
up a hymnbook you don't say let's sing page 97
because the hymnbook does not have pages it has
hymn numbers and one member came to me she said
pastor what i like about you you tell us things
no one has ever told us and we perhaps would never
hear you sing him numbers you don't sing pages
now that's a little thing i know that and i'm
getting to a little thing in the sermon you see
how many of you have ever written a term paper
can i see your hands is there a certain way to
write the footnotes are you with me where do
you put a semicolon a colon when you italicize
when you underline is there a certain way yes or
no yes if you write a doctrinal dissertation there
is something called a format and the reason why
i'm stressing this is that one of our problems
is we are too casual we are too slack in the
way we do the things of god and god does not
bless slackness he does not bless carelessness
he does not bless well-intentioned sloppiness
god is organized he's disciplined
he is regular he's systematic if you do
not believe me study the physical laws
you look as though i just punished you let me
stop punishing you our subject for this afternoon
the great controversy what did i say
the great controversy daniel
chapter one reading from verse 1.
daniel 1 reading from verse 1 the bible says
in the third year of jehoiakim king of judah
came nebuchadnezzar king of babylon unto jerusalem
and besieged it and the lord gave jehoiakim king
of judah into his hand with part of the vessels
of the house of god which he carried into the land
of china to the house of his god and he brought
the vessels into the treasure house of his god
and the king spake unto ashmanas the master of
his eunuchs that he should bring certain of the
children of israel and of the king's seed and
of the princes children in whom with no blemish
but well favored and skillful in all wisdom and
cunning and knowledge and understanding science
and such as had ability in them to stand in
the king's palace and whom they might teach
the learning and the tongue of the chaldeans and
the king appointed them a daily provision of the
king's meat and of the wine which he drank
so nourishing them three years that at the
end thereof they might stand before the king now
among these were of the children of judah daniel
hananiah mishael and azariah unto whom the
prince of the eunuchs gave names for he gave unto
daniel the name of belteshazza antihananaya of
shadrach and to michael of meshach and to azariah
of abednego now read verse 8 with me but daniel
purpose in his heart that he would walk not do
what defile himself with the portion of the
king's maid nor with the wine which he dry
therefore he requested the prince of the
universe that he might not defile himself
the great controversy
the babylonian armies had come three times
i believe 605 598 and 586 and they are taken
with them jewish captives and the third time
they came they destroyed jerusalem left a few
jews there and took most of the population
away scattered them around so they could not
really form some viable opposition or rebellion
nebuchadnezzar being a very wise king he
thought that he would take some of the very best
of the babylonian young men and train them
to administer the kingdom of babylon but in
order to do that the king had to make them less
jewish and as much babylonian as he possibly could
did you follow what i just said he
had to undermine their jewishness
and make them babylonian so that they would
think babylonian and therefore be an asset
through his administration
the bible says in verse 4
children in whom was no blemish but well favored
skillful in all wisdom cunning in knowledge
understanding science and such as had ability
in them to stand in the king's palace and whom
they might teach the learning and the tongue
of the chaldeans one way to enter into the
culture of a people is to study the language
are you following me language is one
of my my favorite language outside of
english is swahili from east africa any east
africans no where are you from nairobi nairobi
all right don't ask me what i said that's between
him and me don't look so nosy between him and me
so i love swahili and when i hear swahili speaker
speak it badly i just get unhappy now in swahili
to have is to be with kuwa now
am i right you see kuana is
quite to be na is with to be with so it tells
me that somewhere in the swahili tradition
the concept of possession was not so strong it
was more i am with it not so much i possess it
i am with it and i like that so when you pass on
someone else is with it are you following me so as
you study language you gain insights into the
thinking of the people nebuchadnezzar decided
he would teach these young men and we're focusing
on daniel hananiah michelle and azariah he would
teach them the language and the learning of
the chaldeans another word for babylonians
he also did something else unto whom the prince
of the eunuchs gave names verse 7 of daniel 1
for he gave unto daniel the name of beltashasa and
to hananiah of shadrach and to mishael of meshach
and to abednego of azariah and azariah abednego
a name in the hebrew context is very serious
because the name expressed what character
those boys could have learned all the chaldean
language they chose but to really target the
character he had to change the name and while he
did not know that but that's a biblical principle
did not god change abraham's name did he not
change jacob's name did he not tame syria's name
god has a way of changing names when something
happens in the life now that you have changed
you need a new name so nebuchadnezzar all
unconsciously follows a biblical principle
now you're no longer in jerusalem you are
in babylon you need a name that reflects
a change in your life i am giving you
babylonian names attached to babylonian gods
shadrach meshach abednego belted all somehow
attached to babylonian gods but daniel hannonia
mishael azariah were names attached somehow to
the god of heaven and earth can you say amen so
both sets of names were attached to uh well i
don't want to use deity for both but just for
god heaven and earth but you understand what
i mean now you have a different set of gods
in jerusalem they had one god they still hadn't
they because they didn't realize that at first
in babylon they have all kinds of gods
and the names reflect your connection
when jacob robbed esau of his
birthright and his blessing
in genesis 27 36 when esau realized his blessing
was gone earlier on his birthright had been taken
by his own folly he said is not he rightly named
jacob notice the wording is not he rightly named
jacob for he hath supplanted me these two times
just a plan to receive esau says within the huge
the jewish tradition jacob has the right name
it matches his one his character and then he
describes the character he took away my birthright
and behold now he has taken away my blessing
matthew 1 21 and she shall bring forth the son and
thou shalt do what call his name what jesus why
for he shall save his people not only character
but life's work is associated with the name
and so our commander is michael what does
michael mean who is like god nebuchadnezzar
changed the names of daniel hananiah mishael and
azariah and years ago i decided not to call them
shadrach meshach and abednego anymore i called
him daniel hananiah mishael azariah now sometimes
i have to add the babylonian names because many
adventists don't even know they had jewish names
so when you say hananiah mishael and
azariah you confuse a lot of adventures
they don't know who you're talking about
but i just want to refer to these young boys
as they were by the names their god-fearing
parents gave them daniel hananiah mishael
azariah you're saying what does this have to
do with the weekend that deals with uh sexual
behavior and so on and so forth i'm coming to
that what's our subject the great controversy
nebuchadnezzar gave them a
babylonian curriculum verse 4.
then he gave them a babylonian diet verse 5.
and he gave them babylonian names verse 7.
what three things did the nebuchadnezzar do what
did he change the name what else did he change
the diet what else did he change
the curriculum three things
if you study daniel chapter one
there is no record of daniel what are the
three boys called come on tell me what
are they called hananiah see what i mean
mishael and azariah what's wrong with you
there is no record of those boys raising
a fuss about the change of the curriculum
no controversy because they
had the right foundation
are you following me they had
been taught on the mother's knees
at the father's feet they had a foundation
that no subsequent construction could affect
no controversy recorded that they opposed
this curriculum what was the other thing the
beginners did he gave them new names there
is no record in daniel that those four boys
raised the fuss about the names they were given
you see people can call you whatever they like
it's not what people call you that count
with god it's what you call yourself
you said amen but you don't follow me was daniel's
name as given by nebuchadnezzar belter shazam
now if you read daniel 7 15 i daniel was grieved
in my spirit in the midst of my body and the
visions of my head trouble me now what are the
two key words in that verse i daniel not i belter
no one said anything are you with me have i lost
you daniel 8 15 it came to pass when i even i
daniel saw the vision and sought for the meaning
that behold they stood before me as the appearance
of a man i daniel daniel 9 verse 2 in his first
year i daniel sought by books the number of years
daniel 10 2 he knows this i daniel this morning
three full weeks it is i daniel daniel 10 7
daniel 12 5. i daniel daniel 27 i daniel fainted
regardless of the fact that nebuchadnezzar called
him belty shazza and we see that in daniel
2 27 the king answered and said unto daniel
whose name was beltashatta i was unable to make
known to me the dream that i have seen and the
interpretation thereof the babylonians called him
back to shazza what did daniel call himself daniel
when gabriel came what did gabriel call him daniel
not belter so heaven still recognized daniel
what do your friends call you
they can call you whatever they like
but don't give them practical reason to give
you a terrible name don't let them call you lazy
because you've given them calls for that
don't let them call you slack because you've
given them reason don't let them call you
whatever because i have given them reason
but let me say again it is not what people call
you it is how you recognize who you are you're
calling your mission this life and
the name that you choose for yourself
so i am a seventh-day adventist not just
a christian the word christian is nothing
you didn't hear me when someone says christian
we say well you know this is supposed to be a
christian nation they were the ones dropping
bombs on whomever it's a christian nation
are you with me christian means nothing
because everybody is a christian seventh-day
adventist i get one mercy i need two more
why are you so quiet
sev okay thanks several the
adventist that means something
the name seventh is a standing
rebuke to the protestant world
here is the line of distinction
between those who worship god
and those who worship the beast and receive
his mark the name itself is a rebuke
she says in testimonies volume 1 page 23
paragraph 1 i was shown in regard to the
remnant people of god choosing a name two
classes were presented before me one class
embraced the great bodies of professed christians
they were trampling upon god's law and bowing
to a people institution they were keeping the
first day of the week at the sabbath of the lord
the other class who were but few in number
were bowing to the great law giver they were
keeping the fourth commandment the peculiar
and prominent features of their faith were
observance of the seventh day and waiting for the
appearing of our lord from heaven she was shown
that name seventh the advertised
and when you understand that
you take pride in that name
and so nebuchadnezzar changed their names they
did not fuss because they understood who they were
many years ago i worked for the salvation army
as a social worker emergency social worker
and i was sitting in my office and i
had my name plate facing those who came
and this lady came she sat down and she looked
at my nameplate s-k-e-e-t-e to me very simple
and she did let you know have you ever
seen a parrot on a perch in a case
and she said mr scheckerty and i said yes
well i'm not lying in the presence
of god she said mr skecherty and i
said yes because i know who can finish it who i am
i was preaching in kenya in dubai
angu and this little boy he came
i was there four weeks every night this little
boy enjoyed the preaching he gave me a card
but he could not figure out the pronunciation of
my name on the card he wrote to past a handy skirt
don't call me but i know
skirts are handy but not for me
but he called me pastor handy skirt but i said
thank you i didn't correct him no that would
have been criminal i loved the little boy and
i took that card it came from his heart but i
know my name is randy skeet not handy skirt so
it didn't bother me now do you know who you are
daniel knew who he was so nebuchadnezzar could
call him beltisa or belty anything else made no
difference to daniel and so daniel and his
three or four friends did not raise a stink
over the change in the
curriculum what's our subject
the great context they did not object
there's no record to the change in the name
but when the diet was announced now
they arose what a great controversy
now you tell me is diet important oh yes have you
ever wondered why a key book of prophecy is first
chapter is based on dying now the first chapter
of any book is essential to understanding the book
many of us cannot grasp the teachings of
daniel in revelation because of the way we eat
i knew you died down
i knew it you're not listening to me sometimes
i get emails i get them from all over the world
let's explain daniel 11. explain daniel 11.
oh explain this and explain that people want
shortcuts to bible knowledge you see because
study takes effort but you grow your mind expands
so people find daniel revelation very difficult
to understand let me make a recommendation for you
change your diet amen change
it get a prophetic diet
i can see it on your face what is a
prophetic diet one that does not include meat
a lot of sugar a lot of
fat or too much of anything
one that keeps you close to the earth
close to what was recommended in eden because god
knew that diet would benefit the mind councils and
dads and foods page 132 paragraph three the mind
is seriously affected by what we eat and drink now
nebuchadnezzar knew that he knew that you know
why speakers don't like to speak after lunch
you know why people go to sleep
you know why they're going to sleep because
the stomachs are full the blood is gone
from the brain it's taking care of digestion
whatever else it does and so they go to sleep
as teacher once told me many young
people are given ritalin young people
boys and girls in school for whatever
simply because they are reacting to the
diets they eat the breakfast they have
when they come to school in the morning
and if the breakfast could be
changed the behavior will change
and you will have fewer of the millions
of children doped up on ritalin
and so daniel and the three hebrew boys raise
and organize stink over the change of the diet
that was a great controversy and
daniel decided in verse 8 of daniel 1
and daniel purpose in his heart the
heart meaning the mind not the organ
that pumps blood what does it
mean to purpose in your heart
to what to resolve someone say something else
do you know what to decide we have resolved
this give me another synonym make up your mind
in purpose in his heart not just daniel
the four boys daniel represents all four
but if you read 417 as for these four children god
gave them knowledge and skill in all learning and
wisdom all for purpose in their heart but daniel
is the lead figure he would not defile his body
with the portion of the king's meat nor with
the wine which is right why use the word defile
the jews would do everything to avoid
defilement because the firemen ultimately
had a spiritual terminus when
jesus was wrongly condemned
and he went before pilate the jews would not
go in there they did not want to be defiled
are you with me they can murder jesus
but they don't want to be defiled
couldn't go into the judgment hall to
be defiled jews were very sensitive
to defilement and daniel understood that
diet will affect my mind and my character
and so he said i'm not eating that
stuff and i'm not drinking that wine
here's what four modern young people
might have said might have said
they're not present in this church somewhere
else let's eat the stuff what's the big thing
about meat is this three years what's wrong
with a little wine we love to reason with god
and negotiate with god and rationalize with god
when god says very simply and very plainly don't
do that don't do that we find reasons we bring
logic so aristotle becomes our god and our guide
let me underscore what i'm trying to say
when daniel said i'm not eating that meat
do you realize the risk he was taking let
me tell you the risk verse 10 of daniel 1
the prince of the eunuch said unto daniel
i fear the lord my king what is he saying
i am scared to death of nebuchadnezzar who
have appointed your meat and your drink for
why should he fight see your faces worse liking
than children which are of your sword then shall
you make me what and danger what my head to
whom the king the man says to daniel look
this attitude of yours will put my life at
risk because if i don't carry through the
king's recommendations my head will be cut
off this king does not rule by committee
that's how serious it was i prefer to
die then defile my body and my mind
whatever defiles the body defiles the mind and if
the mind is defiled the decisions will be affected
let me bring something else to
your consciousness oh it's already
19 after eight let me hurry up and finish
notice verse 4 of daniel verse
5 of daniel 1. do you have it
what are the first two words are the
first three words and who the king
who selected the diet who's higher
than the king or who was no one
who do you think has the best food in babylon
the king who had the best chefs the king
which means that what nebuchadnezzar
offered those four boys
was the very best that babylon had to
offer ah you missed it i'm so discouraged
you're not listening to me all those of
you listening say amen okay i'm shocked
babylon offered daniel named the three hebrew boys
ah yes i heard noise noise babylon offered
daniel hannony michelle and azariah the very best
food in babylon now babylon was the leading
nation on earth they had the best earthly diet
but the best that the world has to offer
is not good enough for the child of god
we need to learn that in food in dress in in
recreation in entertainment and how we spend
our money in our romantic life the best the
world has to offer is not good enough for you
so don't come and tell me research says
that you should eat six little meals a day
now you've read that you've seen it
on youtube and the diet videos huh
it's called grazing eat six little meals ella
white says uh-uh now ella white has never
done research and i don't care she did or not
she got research directly from heaven now the
brightest minds tell you eat six little meals
a day and give your stomach how much rest none
what does inspiration say two or three that's it
and don't eat between are you listening to
me don't eat anything between but what do
the phd say with all respect to phds and rip
whatever you have don't eat between meals
now you look at all the phds and the chemical is
this something nutritional chemistry or something
is there something whatever it is you look at
that that body it's intimidating when you see phd
edd what are all the d's and you look at
alan white what does she have nothing d
and you with your degree are required
to obey and believe that woman
who had no degree but what she offers is
not an earthly source it is from above
and you must be willing to suffer the slings
and arrows of your friends who laugh at you
that personal trainer you
waste god's money spending on
who tells you eat six small meals a day and you
do it another white is rolling over in her grave
and the angels are asking themselves
what's wrong with this absinthe
how do you choose babylon over jerusalem
let me say again at 23 after eight daniel
offered not daniel nebuchadnezzar offered
those four hebrew boys the very best he
had to offer nothing on earth was better
because that was the leading kingdom on
the earth daniel said i don't want it
the spirit just told me going to this
area let me get into your business
wherever i go i counsel
young ladies and old ladies
on romance i'm not an expert but i just give the
bible i know why that's it pastor pray for me
why i'm involved with a man who doesn't come to
church so my first response is and it's a very
naughty response why wouldn't a good seventh-day
adventist like your boyfriend not come to church
why wouldn't he come to church a
nice adventist grew up in the church
his grandfather was william miller
why wouldn't he come to church
you know what she says they all say
he is not a seventh-day adventist
i said sister let me give it to you straight i
mean straight between the eye take your glasses
off to connect yourself with an unbeliever
is to place yourself on satan's ground
you grieve the spirit of god and forfeit
his protect what does forfeit mean give up
now this is not james dobson writing
this is not marilyn hickey this is not
joyce meyer any of those are the well-dressed
false prophets this is wisdom from above
to connect with an unbeliever is to
place yourself on satan's ground now
what do i usually get back
but he's a good methodist
i don't care i just don't care white rise to
this young lady who had the same argument led
us to young lovers speech 87 paragraph three
here's what she says though the young man
she says of your choice we're in all other
respects worthy and then in brackets which is not
yet he has not accepted the truth
for this time he is an unbeliever
in other words to the adventist mind an unbeliever
is someone who does not believe and practice
present truth i don't care if he's the best
methodist on the face of the earth and elsewhere
he's a good catholic i don't care by the way
for those of you who are in that condition now
make up your mind before you leave
this building the relationship is done
are you with me is that a guilty laugh
system are you with me the relationship
is done here's what you do because you
see the unbeliever will take you from god
and you may be practicing just what we're
talking about today and this weekend you
know why god told the israelites don't mingle
with the the canaanites the amorites he said
they will turn your heart from me he never
said you will turn their hearts to me he said
they will turn your heart from me which means
there is no such thing as boyfriend evangelism
here's what you do you call that man or
that woman you're involved with illegally
it's illegal in the eyes of god and you say
whatever his name is barabbas i've called
to tell you i made a mistake i misled you into
thinking that my church tolerates this behavior
i have misled you into thinking that all the
young ladies in my church are just like i am
i was wrong i've come called to apologize for that
and to tell you that based on my conviction my god
has spoken to me my love for my church i have to
dissolve this relationship and this call is that
it is not a call to discuss possibilities for
baptism this is a call to end the relationship
tonight
if it's a woman calling a man call announce
and hang up because you can argue with the man
no you can't you ask eve you
cannot argue with the man
men know naturally how to twist your head
men am i right women you know i'm
right just announce it and that's it
if you're a man calling a woman you announce it
and that's it i don't care how much she
cries you must have a heart of holy flint
listen to me go to patriarchs and prophets read
the chapter on seth and enoch by ellen white
have you ever reflected on the fact that the
chapter that introduces the conditions that
led to the flood begins with mixed marriage and it
came to pass when men began to dwell upon the face
of the earth and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of god saw the dollars of men that
they were fair and they took them wives of always
their choice ellen white says the holy line they
lived in the mountains the sinful line descended
from cain they lived in the valleys and the plains
and the men from the holy line began drifting into
the valleys the sinful women were very beautiful
and before long they intermingled
eloise said it led to the very
worst results now as you heard during dr jackson
it never happens overnight but it happens
any practice contrary to divine
guidance will lead to bad results
this lady called me pastor need to
talk to you we sat in the office
yes what's the problem my husband takes my son
to uh games on sabbath i said well what's the
problem with that is your husband an adventist
no are you an adventist yes when you married him
did you know he was not an adventist she said
yes i said well tell me what do you want me to do
now when people say pray for
me i don't waste time why
because i'm not wasting god's time are
you with me two weeks later came back
hasn't got to talk to you about what my
husband puts pork in the refrigerator
i said sister he an adventist no did
you know that when you married him yes
he has a right to put a living
pig in that refrigerator
he already came to me in a certain
part of the world pray for my boyfriend
why he won't come to church you
know my response why wouldn't a nice
well-raised seventh-day adventist young man
not come to church she put her head down
pastor he's not an adventist i said
what do you want me to pray and say
i'm serious i ask ah he'll come to church
i said no i won't pray for that here's what
i'll pray and say that god will give you the
decency to go and tell him i made a mistake i'm
sorry for giving you the wrong impression all
the girls in the administration not that easy
you did you want me to repeat it you didn't
hear me all the girls in the adventist church
are not that easy and you're sorry and
god bless him and you let god save him
she put her head down and walked away
what am i saying if we want to avoid
what we're talking about this weekend one
thing we need to avoid is mixed relationships
are you with me and so as we conclude the great
controversy the best babylon had to offer with
respect to food was not good enough for daniel
what are the three boys called hananiah michelle
the best catholic on earth could be the
nephew of pope benedict is not suited
for you why because you
are a seventh-day adventist
you're not better than you're different from are
you listening to me patriarchs and prophets page
126 paragraph one ella white writes of abraham now
that abraham was in a special sense connected with
heaven he must dwell among strangers his character
must be peculiar differing from all the world
all the world needs all the catholics that
were back then all the baptists all the mormons
all the scientologists all the pentecostals all
the presbyterians all the jehovah's witnesses
all the church of satan folk his character
had to be different from all the world
and that difference must be seen in our dress our
diet our relationships our everything and that is
no joke when i listen to dr jackson's presentation
and we're having struggle with well i can't tell
you what they're women among us but we were
having some struggles as to what is appropriate
for a man and a woman when i my personal
conclusion is we are so affected by the world
you're listening to me that the
concept of a different lifestyle
sounds extreme you miss what i said we are
so worldlyfied i just made up that word
that when god's original standard is presented
we back off and back up it sounds strange so when
moses was going to the israelites he told god look
you better give me a name for the israelites why
they don't know you i need a name
they don't know you listen we serve
a god who is the god of separation
genesis 1 reading from verse 1 the bible says in
the beginning god created the heaven and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved
upon the face of the waters
and god said let there be light and there
was light and god saw the light that it
was good now read the rest with me and
god divided the light from the darkness
now that's physical creation but physical creation
teaches spiritual lessons we serve a creator
who wants us to understand by the way he created
i do not want light and darkness coexisting
for ye were sometimes darkness now are ye
light in the lord walk as children of light
ephesians 5 8 and that separation
must enter every aspect of our lives
we must play differently and so as we discussed
sexual behavior earlier many of us had a problem
because dr jackson was introducing a standard
of sexual behavior that for our worldly minds
sounded strange so we just couldn't deal with
it some of us i should say in all failures
we couldn't because our standards may be
what you read in uh what's it called um
fm or fham something or playboy or desperate
housewives of atlanta or wherever or
name one they all come from this part of
the world that's where we get our standards
and when holy things are introduced we gag
because we're so worthy let me give
your recommendation as i close the book
take three weeks
and go on a fast not from food come
on say it man i know you're relieved
go on a fast from television well let me be
extreme one week let's work our way up one week
watch no tv not even the news don't even read the
newspaper don't listen to the radio don't download
any rubbish on your ipod ipad nano whatever
maybe i'm out of date your icloud and whatever
here's what you do for one week you
only read the bible and ellen white
accept what is required for your
class in school and your work
you try that see what happens to your mind
now for those of you with children you will have
a civil war because your children will not let
you keep that television off you may have for
the first time to put your feet down as parents
we live in an age when children run to homes
what do you think i'm joking you
know how many parents are afraid
of the children in the adventist church
can't tell them anything you try that
one week of fasting from the world no
basketball no playoffs nor whatever no mma
no olympics
no jeopardy no dancing with the stars
huh no layering liquor games no
no who no baseball no facebook
no facebook one week
and see what god does to our
minds well let me make an appeal
you and i must wage a great controversy
in the area of our diet it affects the
mind the mind affects behavior do you
need to make a change in your diet
have you made a commitment to
make a change in your diet who has
oh i'm very touched god bless you i mean that
stand up stand up stand up you will not regret it
you will not regret it if we would just
do what god says in every area of life
our problems will be slashed by 90. here's my
challenge now one week fasting from the world
give you time to take a deep breath
who will try that are you serious
remember jesus healed a
man who had a withered hand
well if you're joking he can give you a withered
hand are you with me so don't play with jesus he
can give you a withered hand now listen to me
who will try to fast from the world one week
beginning when tonight keep
your hands up no tv no facebook
no myspace no craigslist no whatever what else is
there who twitter no twitter no twatter no nothing
no soap operas what will you
read the bible and ellen why
one week keep your hands up father in
heaven i present these hands to you
we'll try to fast one week from the world in
the precious name of jesus dear god help us to
understand that this challenge must be pursued
one hour at a time give us a strength father
when we weaken under the pressure when our nature
calls for the world give us the strength to say
like daniel i purpose in my heart not to do this
they got in heaven as your people try to purify
themselves by avoiding the world for awake let
them begin to see things in your word let them
begin to understand what was previously a mystery
let them see the beauty of spiritual things
ah father those of us who've made decisions to
change our diet give us the moral courage like
those four hebrew boys to choose the best
that heaven has to offer not babylon and
so god bless us help us to understand what we
eat what we drink what we watch what we read
affects our moral behavior let us wage this great
controversy in your power hear this humble prayer
save us all when you come bring us back tomorrow i
pray from my heart in jesus name and for his sake
let all god's people say amen and amen god
bless you god bless you we'll see you tomorrow
you